THE STATE ATTORNEY SUSPENDED BY FLORIDA
GOVERNOR RON DeSANTIS OVER
ABORTION PLANS -- OVER ABORTION
PLANS TO FILE A MOTION
CHALLENGING THAT SUSPENSION.
DeSANTIS REMOVED ANDREW WARREN
EARLIER THIS MONTH FOR PLEDGING
NOT TO PROSECUTE CRIMES RELATED
TO ABORTION AND GENDER
TRANSITION TREATMENTS FOR
CHILDREN.
DeSANTIS WHO SEEMS TO BE
WEIGHING A 2024 PRESIDENTIAL RUN
ACCUSED WARREN OF NEGLECT OF
DUTY AND INCOMPETENCE.
WARREN A TWICE ELECTED DEMOCRAT
CALLS HIS OUSTER AN ABUSE OF
POWER TO OVERTURN A FREE AND
FAIR ELECTION.
JOINING ME NOW IS THE
HILLSBOROUGH COUNTY STATE
ATTORNEY SUSPENDED BY DeSANTIS,
ANDREW WARREN.
SIR, THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR BEING
WITH US.
WHAT ACTION ARE YOU TAKING THIS
MORNING?
>> WELL, THE GOVERNOR HAS
VIOLATED TWO LAWS, ONE, HE'S
RETALIATED AGAINST ME FOR
SPEAKING OUT AGAINST HIM IN
VIOLATION OF MY FIRST AMENDMENT
RIGHTS, AND HE'S ABUSED THE
POWER THAT HE HAS UNDER THE
FLORIDA CONSTITUTION TO SUSPEND
AN ELECTED OFFICIAL.
SO WE'RE FIGHTING BACK TO MAKE
SURE THAT EVEN THOUGH RON
DeSANTIS IS GOVERNOR, THE FIRST
AMENDMENT STILL HAS MEANING.
THE FLORIDA CONSTITUTION STILL
HAS MEANING AND ELECTIONS STILL
HAVE MEANING.
>> YOU'RE FILING A MOTION IN
COURT, FEDERAL COURT, ON WHAT
GROUNDS EXACTLY?
>> WELL, THERE ARE TWO GROUNDS,
ONE IS A FIRST AMENDMENT CLAIM
BECAUSE HE'S VIOLATING MY FIRST
AMENDMENT RIGHTS, AND THE FIRST
AMENDMENT APPLIES TO EVERYBODY,
THAT'S THE BEAUTY OF T THAT'S
WHY THEY PUT IT UP FRONT IN THE
CONSTITUTION, TOO.
THE SECOND CLAIM IS BASICALLY
JUST TO HAVE THE COURT ADMIT AND
SHOW THAT WHAT HE'S DONE ABUSES
HIS AUTHORITY UNDER THE FLORIDA
CONSTITUTION.
HE CAN'T JUST SUSPEND AN
ELECTION, HE CAN'T JUST THROW
OUT PEOPLE'S VOTES BECAUSE HE
DISAGREES WITH SOMETHING THAT
I'VE SAID.
>> ON THE FIRST POINT YOU SAY
FREE SPEECH.
WHAT THIS IS OVER IS A PLEDGE
THAT YOU SIGNED AND HE WOULD
ARGUE A PROMISE THAT YOU MADE
NOT TO PROSECUTE PEOPLE WHO
VIOLATE ABORTION LAWS IN
FLORIDA.
YOU SIGNED A PLEDGE WITH OTHER
PROSECUTORS THAT SAYS, QUOTE, WE
DECLINE TO USE OUR OFFICE'S
RESOURCES TO CRIMINALIZE
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH DECISIONS
AND COMMIT TO EXERCISE OUR WELL
SETTLED DISCRETION AND REFRAIN
FROM PROSECUTING THOSE WHO SEEK.
SO YOU'RE SAYING THAT SPEECH,
BUT HE'S SAYING YOU'RE TELLING
PEOPLE YOU ARE NOT GOING TO DO
YOUR JOB.
>> WELL, LET'S BE CLEAR, FIRST
OF ALL, THAT'S A VALUE STATEMENT
THAT I SIGNED ON TO TALKING
ABOUT THAT I BELIEVE THAT
CRIMINALIZING HEALTH CARE
DECISIONS BETWEEN WOMEN AND
THEIR DOCTORS IS NOT SOMETHING
THAT WE SHOULD BE CRIMINALIZING.
SECOND, THAT LAW, THE 15-WEEK
ABORTION BAN THAT WAS PASSED BY
THE FLORIDA LEGISLATURE HAS BEEN
HELD UNCONSTITUTIONAL.
SO WHEN I BECAME STATE ATTORNEY
I PUT MY HAND ON THE BIBLE AND I
SWORE TO UPHOLD BOTH THE U.S.
AND THE STATE CONSTITUTIONS AND
THAT'S WHAT I'M DOING.
SO I CAN'T ENFORCE AN
UNCONSTITUTIONAL LAW AND NO CASE
HAS COME BEFORE ME YET.
THIS ISN'T ABOUT ANYTHING THAT
I'VE DONE, THIS IS ABOUT WHAT
I'VE SAID.
>> IF A CASE COMES BEFORE YOU
THAT VIOLATES A LAW THAT IS
DEEMED CONSTITUTIONAL ON
ABORTION, WILL YOU PROSECUTE IT?
>> WELL, WE WOULD LOOK AT IT THE
SAME WAY WE WOULD LOOK AT EVERY
SINGLE ONE OF THE 50,000 TO
60,000 CASE THAT IS COME TO MY
OFFICE EVERY YEAR.
WE LOOK AT THE LAW AND WE LOOK
AT THE FACTS AND THEN WE MAKE A
DECISION ON THAT CASE BASED ON
CASE-SPECIFIC INFORMATION.
>> IF THE 15-WEEK BAN ULTIMATELY
IS DEEMED CONSTITUTIONAL BASED
ON THE FLORIDA STATE
CONSTITUTION, AGAIN, IF SOMEONE
VIOLATES THAT, WOULD YOU
PROSECUTE?
>> I MEAN, AGAIN, YOU'RE ASKING
QUESTIONS IN A HYPOTHETICAL.
I SAID WE HAVE TO EVALUATE THE
MERITS OF EACH CASE.
I WILL TELL YOU EVEN UNDER
CURRENT LAW, RIGHT, THE 15-WEEK
BAN IS UNCONSTITUTIONAL, BUT
GOING BACK TO THE ROE STANDARD
IN FLORIDA OF 24 WEEKS, THERE'S
A DIFFERENCE BETWEEN SOMEONE WHO
HAS AN ABORTION AT 24 WEEKS AND
THERE'S A QUESTION AS TO WHETHER
IT WAS 23 WEEKS AND 6 DAYS OR 24
WEEKS AND ONE DAY VERSUS SOMEONE
WHO HAS A WHACK ALLEY ABORTION
AT 35 WEEKS.
THAT'S WHY WE SAY WE HAVE TO
LOOK AT THE FACTS OF EVERY
SPECIFIC CASE.
YOU CAN'T SAY I'M ALWAYS GOING
TO OR NEVER GOING TO IN
SITUATIONS.
THAT'S NOT HOW PROSECUTING
WORKS.
>> IT'S INTERESTING, ARE YOU
SAYING THAT HE THE RIGHT TO
SUSPEND YOU OR REMOVE YOU FROM
YOUR OFFICE IF ULTIMATELY YOU
DID MAKE THAT DECISION NOT TO
PROSECUTE?
>> NO, NOT AT ALL.
I MEAN, THE FLORIDA CONSTITUTION
SETS VERY LIMITED PARAMETERS
UNDER WHICH A GOVERNOR CAN
SUSPEND AN ELECTED OFFICIAL.
WHAT'S HAPPENING HERE IS HE'S
TRYING TO OVERTURN A FREE AND
FAIR ELECTION.
HE'S TRYING TO THROW OUT THE
VOTES OF HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS
OF FLORIDIANS AND TRYING TO
SUBSTITUTE HIS JUDGMENT FOR THAT
OF THE VOTERS WHO ELECTED ME.
EVEN MY 8-YEAR-OLD UNDERSTANDS
THIS.
THIS IS HOW DEMOCRACY WORKS.
THE PEOPLE GET TO ELECT THE --
THEIR ELECTED LEADERS AND THE
PEOPLE ELECTED ME BECAUSE THEY
TRUST MY JUDGMENT, THEY SHARE MY
VISION AND THEY'VE SEEN THE
SUCCESS WE HAVE HAD IN KEEPING
HILLSBOROUGH COUNTY ONE OF THE
SAFEST COUNTIES IN THE STATE OF
FLORIDA.
>> TO BE CLEAR YOU WERE ELECTED
TWICE IN HILLSBOROUGH COUNTY,
THE VOTERS TWICE ELECTED YOU.
NOW WHATEVER HAPPENS IN COURT,
THIS CAN ALSO GO TO THE FLORIDA
STATE SENATE.
DO YOU THINK THAT THE FLORIDA
STATE SENATE WOULD UPHOLD YOUR
APPEAL TO THEM?
>> WELL, THE FLORIDA STATE
SENATE HAS A ROLE TO PLAY, BUT
ONLY IN A SITUATION WHERE THE
GOVERNOR'S SUSPENSION IS WITHIN
THE LAW.
HERE THE GOVERNOR'S SUSPENSION
IS CLEARLY OUTSIDE THE LAW SO WE
DON'T EXPECT IT EVER TO GET TO
THE SENATE.
>> ANDREW WARREN, THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR JOINING US THIS
MORNING.
APPRECIATE IT.
>> THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
HAVING ME.